[Music]
happy Friday everybody hello there hey
Ben hi how you doing John Luke I'm
pretty good nice
it's Friday it is Friday and you know
what that means it's time for some
monster hunter oh and we're here staring
at the sky for some season what you did
doing he's let's not talk about it he's
having a real real rough time of it yeah
is he doing the thing from Fist of the
North Star that could be it
it's kind of looks like maybe the thing
but yeah we're we're back
it's Friday event question % we're doing
all sorts of cool fun things yeah we're
doing we're starting out of 2 instead of
11 cuz uh see a thieves stream someone
pirated our time away he was actually
really fun I was kind of on yeah I was I
was helping out it was fun to watch
Hey they should make um you should make
cosmic cure you a skin in this game yes
I should and he just kicks everything
feels like a kick emote yeah exactly
and it doesn't launch just sign me on to
do all that I'm so I'm so down for all
right so yeah guys once again new we
have the stream ID right here so please
join in we're playing on the PlayStation
4 PlayStation 4 hang out do quests with
us do quests with other people will have
all have a wonderful hunting time all
right I'm going to oh you're posting it
up right away we're digging right in
going right into it let's see here what
do we got
wait for me one arm wrestle oh you know
what if you don't make it in here by the
time we disembark
we will I'll arm wrestle you never have
these these three Raptor boys oh we're
jumping right into there's gonna be a
fun time flash-in-the-pan I like it a
simple task oh that's weird
so simple task it was supposedly a rank
30 but on the quest this is rank 9 oh
really
yeah huh that's weird I shouldn't be
posting I should be joining or maybe
it's like a
I throw Springs different dozen Hunter I
thought those were the same rank
oh it's it's so like this says it's a
six star quest but the rank you need to
be is 11
oh yes you're right now sure so how into
this I am damn I didn't do that I also
need to just clear out some of my
vouchers so was asking about how long
our streams are typically an hour and a
half or so yeah we kind of triangle at
least an hour an hour then we kind of
feel like if we're really into it like
well we'll keep going that kind of thing
we only stream for 15 minutes at a time
yeah we have to stop dang papa CBS has
weird restrictions on us so basically
you can't hunt monsters for more than 15
minutes apiece just that we do that
where they if you play too long with
Papa music say like hey check outside
what are you doing in here stop playing
get out it's 12 in the morning right now
for me mr. chilled gamer the chillest of
gamers just 12:12 like 12:00 noon 12:00
noon or like 12:00 at night
we already got a third person in here
Wow we're killing it I love it
damn yeah I love it
that's the weird thing about talking
about 12 like you could say 12 morning
like technically 12:00 at midnight is
the morning but also 12 noon is still
kind of like morning feeling time you
know right so I gotta like give myself
like a special like I've got to say like
noon or midnight instead of like we
decided to do that rather than just the
full 24 hours I don't know military time
is too difficult what's the logic behind
that the only reason military time is
difficult though is because you have to
remember be like okay wait so convert
that to talk okay 15 oh so it's like 3
o'clock like dang but otherwise if we
all just knew it's like yeah Manas 23 o
clock
oh that's just maybe it doesn't have
enough it's good never felt it at night
it's dark AF oh shoot
well I'm glad the cheer you're staying
up late into the night hanging out with
yeah I guess scheme spot after dark for
you we're though we're the Late Show oh
I like that idea
yeah right game spot spot after dark Oh
Al's mood and Cameron and
pelipper we got more people V Phoenix
returning once again and Jake my brain
just did a big hurt because I realized
that we're inside of this this arena and
I have my actual gear
oh shoot you're right I was like what
[Music]
yeah alright so I'm gonna try to go
close these other two off and maybe we
can just straight murder this boy before
anyone else no magic we're gonna get him
pretty quick whoop these boys are not
yeah tough whoa
our friend here has got an awesome
looking set oh shoot look at that sword
it's some good fashioned hunter going
that's pretty cool again we should just
do a show where we have people come into
the lobby and then we we grade their
their outfits like a Project Runway yeah
like a Project Runway but for Monster
Hunter okay alright you're into it I'm
very into it okay okay
you're selling me on this I'm kind of
like like when it's a when it's kind of
a lighter week you know and there's not
really like a like a big amount of quest
or something or it's just like oh
they're making us fight oh and your net
for the 67th time we should just do a
like a good old Monster Hunter fashion
show I like that oh shoot man even that
far away he's is a real real flashy boy
he did I need to like get my head in the
game I'm like half half minutes Sam now
Sam well V Phoenix is back in here
hanging out yeah I love the Phoenix
joined us
I do love when you get behind his flash
though because you're just free to just
do remove it's okay I don't want to get
any level ups on this at all I want any
spirit blade complete combos at all you
do what I dare you
that works I'll take it oh boy oh this
is not what I want
thank you I can't do a thing on the wall
here some some real good pro maneuvers
and knocking me out of that cuz im a
skrub and didn't know how owls moon says
they joined that fashion show heck yeah
Kuroko also says they would love it I
feel like what we need to do is we need
to like give everyone like a week
advanced warning yeah exactly
next week is when we'll do it and then
we'll get like everyone to get there
through their best outfits yeah
yeah I like that idea a lot show gamer
since I'd love to play with you guys try
on the client xbox oh no man I can't
wait till we get to that um that PC now
that cross-play life everything just
boss play and everyone can just play
with each other and it's a wonderful you
know utopia we're all doing drum circles
and oh man I play monster that's that's
the dream that's what we're headed for
yeah on the peak in its drum circles
Monster Hunter yeah that would that
would actually be really nice I kind of
like how the tech is there you have the
ability to do it like it was for tonight
right that did the accidental like the
accidentally turn it on yeah I'm trying
to get this guy over here like rocket
leagues like yeah we could totally do it
and they kind of do with like ps4 and PC
like or no sorry Xbox
no now ps4 and PC you can't actually
with rocket League yeah but there's like
like cross they can't cross between Xbox
and let's just play both of these yeah
I'm down yeah screw it I'm just happy
that we're not doing three at the same
time because I feel like the three
flashes would be yeah that maybe be a
little obnoxious yeah so wait for a long
time oh they're talking about the PC
release yeah yeah you're gonna have to
wait a bit unfortunately it'll be worth
it though I think yeah I think there's
enough people who are really excited for
this game on PC they it's not like oh no
one's gonna be playing here
so if you're okay waiting man yeah man
yeah yes that's fine mess up your
fingers and my thumb stores so it's the
whole thing with these boys is up
there's like a new headgear for them or
something I think so Wow and you want to
know what's apparently what our title
says you want me to spoil it for you
because I think I shouldn't spoil it for
you don't spoil it for me if it's like a
cool I spoiled it for myself and I kind
of wish I had is it just in the armor
that it'll be in the armors that we can
you'll see it when we cut it sit like a
is it like a see like it's not a set
it's just uh just a headgear oh it's
like a whole separate yeah but it goes
it goes really well with what we're
doing
cool should fight energy ghonte next I I
do need to uh actually farms from near
Gurgaon oh yes you need to build your
your claws right I want some claws I
also have some other yeah I want to
build that crit so once we get through
all our events if we want to we want to
do some some proper honey both it did at
the same time that was crazy I got
double flashed oh shoot
yeah I'm sorry to hear that
Ventus definitely closing your your hand
inside of a doors not a good way to go
oh that's no good
especially if you like playing video
games like like all of us do kind of
need those definitely there's part of me
that's like half looking out for
whenever the next like flashes coming so
I'm not like jumping in but I should
probably be jumping in oh my god shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot mm-hmm that was
dumb oh that was all of us I've been
smacked
[Music]
and this I can't believe I just wished
to thing that once kind of sucks I would
not want to do the free yeah we could
still kind of try to separate them out
it's okay so I think we're I think we're
doing fine doing all right
no I can see how this would be really
obnoxious with a third I'm I'm pretty
sure the the helmet that you get
actually helps with just this thing
specifically to haha that's that's
pretty good if you ever want to like
after you get all the parts farmed up
you know like come back and do it again
hey Matt my friend Matt's on the chat oh
I should have a cool chat with him yeah
man I'm I think I could do that this
weekend make sure I'm good I think I'm
free Sunday there's this quest with some
randoms fighting a Diablos and three
guys just all fainted all in one move
crazy wolf man that sounds like a rough
hunt and that exists
that sounds real rough was uh was doomed
to fail from the beginning but that's
you know sometimes you get unlucky it's
it's the way it goes but hopefully you
got back in you're able to stuff fight
that Diablos we still haven't beaten the
black Diablos yet don't I think about it
don't not again never again I should
probably probably focus on one of these
the one that I have targeted they're
very similar yeah health-wise down low
just capturing oh that guy's real tired
caPSURE I could actually you want
just going to jump on this boy's head do
you want to go for a capture youngnam
are they do you think they're ready for
capture being I think they are okay I'm
going to gonna knock it flashed it cool
yeah yeah I'm gonna lay down trap over
here if you could lure him over to me
I'm gonna run over you I'm gonna also
pull out some tranq bombs just gonna
hang out all right they've got the
message put on my bandit mantle so I
look really cool then I know one of them
died I think I agree nice to meet you
it's all my shortcuts get changed do I
not have come on go for it come on
right here right here buddy right here
just get on in
come on oh okay or we got that you do
that I can't I can't get out of my emote
now no he thinks just uh did it all take
off taking the lead he's like I got this
guy's don't even why I didn't make sure
we carved that other boy first before he
disappears yeah
did we get that other car yes we did
it's like you're fighting off the
paparazzi right now that's actually
really really accurate
I don't think I finished carving I
didn't either that was a really short
one there just like you don't need these
parts don't even I kind of do though
look at all these things we got do I got
a black crystal ticket black Christmas
that is that for the how many do we need
that's a good question I actually kind
of think it might be worth it if it's
not too many to actually get it on the
stream now I'm totally down if it's not
too many yeah cuz it'll it'll definitely
need to find out it'll enhance the
experience tenfold
oh one of new events has your fighting
oh wow apparently can make a good amount
of money in one of the new events oh I'm
guessing it's probably the gathering one
that we all thought was angry pickle
monster coming back it's not it's bummer
yeah yeah I'm sure we'll hear about
almost like such an obvious bait and
switch
yeah see all right I'm gonna go check
this out we're gonna see what this is
cuz it's now in our our thing oh I'm
excited I hope I hope you're ready
how's my gear holding up forge
equipments armor right it's so dumb you
need three of them you do it yeah that's
that's easy we can we can knock that out
do it
what is although what is that I mean
this is a new set yeah
yes that looks awesome I I don't I don't
know if I like it as much as the other
year the guild said oh the first one I
[Music]
think this is it yeah oh wow this is
this is good you can change like all the
colors you get that it's just doing
arena stuff I haven't done any much
arena stuff that'd be why I don't have
that Alex job so we should we should
definitely I still oh I've missed out my
wiggler I never got it I was did that
run out I maybe I think I ran out I
think it'll air I think it ran out I had
two tickets to dang dude I never got my
wiggler it'll be back don't don't you
worry they have been bringing the sets
back yeah okay here's the thing with
these shadow shades
I also need like a full black like I
just need to look like a character from
the matrix yeah basically uh so that's
actually what I saw in the image that
spoiled it for me someone did like the
like the the plague doctor outfit but
cuz it on the dudes it looks like a like
a matrix coat yeah kind of I do like the
female version of the guild cross though
I can't remind ya do it I can't wait
till here I play you know the PC and I'm
gonna roll a female character instead of
a dude this time so I can just see all
the other yeah 14 of that that looks
cool these shades yeah Saudi here
already got the energy armor and the
dying light switch axe dude you're
killing it
that's a good time oh I was gonna say
weird all your gear go and I realize
you're wearing the hoist ugh yeah that's
cuz I'm wearing that a lawyer set right
now oh man look at all our pals in here
I love it I still need that Fang to
complete so I have all the tickets to do
get the set to get
oh I just need to get that something
that's good well so then you can still
come back later on and get it which is
good yeah I think as long as I have the
ticket I'm always get it yeah here I'm
gonna I'll post it up again all right
and we can do it two more times we'll
just get our sunglasses and wear them
the rest of the time because why not
this game reminds me of Super Mario
Brothers sure yeah I'm in like the movie
because that was that I maybe understand
so the flip in what's his toes all those
John Leguizamo and man I haven't watched
that movie in a while Dennis Hopper that
good old Gil Denny Denny hop hopper
hanging out I posted this up without you
being ready also where'd you I'm loading
into the oh that's something this
monitor does for oh it just goes black
ah it's loading you don't need to see
this it's a race John Luke you gotta
beat everyone there oh shoot there's
also a lot of people in here yeah right
now oh boy oh so I got to take a guy you
got to take it down go take it down all
right I'm gonna start it then I can't
abandon my boy jail I gotta bring him
with me
sorry guys see that this is what happens
when we mess with the natural order of
things like I can't I can't be the one
to start the quest I have to join you I
have to I have to be ready for it and go
where's my demon pickle I don't know
Ventus that's what I want to know pursue
I want I want my pickle boy and I want
him now red eyes I recognize red eyes
it runs back in here from hanging out
Creegan I think is new yeah yeah what's
up my dude welcome welcome to the hunt
zone I realized that I like to put zone
at the end of things a lot just because
and I probably should find a new thing
to do also shout outs all the people who
watch this YouTube video
after it gets like archived and point
out how much would say boy all the time
oh is that a thing oh yeah people love
pointing it out and I feel bad because
I'm very conscious of it now wait like
in a way they saying that's a bad like
boy this and boy that boy everything why
is it always boy I'm sorry guy say hey
this is where I am don't be hating on
the boys okay yeah yeah they're good
boys good boys Brent please all right I
got I got my stuff I'm ready to go I'm
set
I've eaten you're making potions yeah I
didn't have any last time so I'm just
gonna make sure I good emirate says is
this game awesome I've never played
Monster Hunter if this looks cool to you
this is the best time to jump in they do
a really good a really good job of kind
of bringing newer people in the best
it's probably ever done because Master
Hunter never has tutorials but uh yeah
if you want to get some cool big monster
fights I wholeheartedly recommend its
problem my favorite game that's come out
this year and I'm a little biased
because I really like Monster Hunter
anyway looks like I just need to make
sure I have enough drinks oh I should
probably fill up my my gear I didn't
even think about that
there we go bombs so we got a bunch of
people with the glasses already I didn't
do anything with the Monster Hunter
stuff yet today before the show I feel
kind of silly about it I'm definitely
liking behind people because I kind of
only play monster on her now during this
dream I've kind of fallen off to like
between all the other things coming like
I had to I do play metal gear survive
when it came out and I know I don't
leave jumping around doing playing a lot
of Yakuza yeah I get ready for six
emotionally physically all of the ways
you need to get prepared for it oh man
[Music]
Hassan Hassan Hassan Hassan hope I got
that right sighs by the way this is my
first
dream here and I'm loving it so far you
guys are so genuine thank you a tribe
yeah very casual off-the-cuff don't care
I'm drinking a beer right now I was
gonna grab one but I I'm s welcome to
Friday can't believe it
all right we should separate him again
because yeah that's a good call
I'm gonna go for that you're gonna get
that switch Oh what is he doing
I'm gonna get that Nintendo switch
that's sweet Nintendo switchport
it's been inside this arena oh no you
can't friend up I didn't even see oh
shoot oh no oh my boy I'm so sorry I'm
really I'm gonna come get you I'm gonna
I'm gonna save you I don't need to save
you you feel terrible Creegan I believe
in you he's gonna he's gonna kill both
of them by the time that thing watch
what he's gonna finish the bolt before
we finish this one I have faith in our
hunter pals also I'm so sorry
like I saw them running and I'm like
well they're gonna keep going right
they're gonna stop and then drew right
there it's okay we knocked you out
you're set oh cool
hi guru knees oh boy Oh
dream Emirates first time here to all
you guys your first time here awesome
I'm gonna give them and give you the
channel pitch so that you know how how
we're doing so GameSpot's streams every
day at 11 a.m.
mm-hmm sometimes we stream a little bit
later because we get bumped for cool
pirate games but uh there's always
something here for you and you should
definitely follow our subscribe so you
don't miss a single one
also because I want you to come back and
I'm gonna miss you if you tell yeah uh
something I wish YouTube did better yeah
was you set the notifications but when
you sign on applications
it just says like yeah you're getting
notifications about everything every
single thing I wish there's a way you
could get specific with it you're like
hey look I only care about the live
stream so just notify me when they go
live or say you're like oh I really only
care about the reviews or I only care
about on the carry history of on
GameSpot's YouTube channel watch those
there I heard they're good buy a cool
guy it's very true but like if you could
say like oh I only notify me when this
playlist gets a new video right yeah
like that would be way better like
imagine if you hit the bell on the thing
and then it brought up a drop-down menu
of checkboxes and you can just yeah so
what do you wanna get notified by now
apparently there's I know at least with
playlists there's sort of a way you can
kind of do that through the mobile app
only but it's also like only through the
mobile app and it's not necessarily
exactly the way we're talking so it's
like you're kind of cheesing it a little
bit yeah they don't have like an
official thing and I wish they did
[Music]
subscribe to notifications oh hell yeah
it is oh yeah looking forward to it's a
scene you pop up hang out with us like
even when when like I'm not on the
stream like I'll be in the chat hanging
out yeah you're moderating a lot heck
yeah
keeping keeping the chat safe streets
clean Ziggy Stardust welcome love your
love your music good old good old stuff
good times
says they're just level five but the
scheme is beautiful there's so much
depth to it yeah ma'am
there's there's a lot a lot of good
content in Master Hunter and if you want
a good video that we actually have up
from a while ago that our pal Mike
McCarty did it does a really good job of
kind of putting into words why this game
is great like yes around
now when like a lot of games are trying
to take advantage of people with like
loot boxes and stuff yeah I believe it's
called like goodbye destiny hello
Lobster honor
yeah yeah it's yeah something he talks
about something I've talked about that I
like about this game is that you look at
games like destiny and a lot of you
times you see people who are like I I
just got to get through the opening of
the game to get to the real game and I'm
like I think this entire game is fun
from start to end like no point did I
ever feel like oh I really got to get
through this story crap so I can get to
like the good part something I haven't
fun the whole time like this game is
just fun it's it's a game that just kind
of goes which I'm really into it it's
like it's very upfront with what it is
someone asks you like yo what's that
Monster Hunter game about just be like
it's all in the name you're hunting
monsters somebody's calling you out for
using Lizzie no Jesus set the sword yeah
is it pronounces he knows you know jivas
you know knows you know jeepers yeah you
know jiva it's it's not my favorite but
I had it equipped from the last time
because I was fighting the engine and
the Rathalos for some stuff okay we
actual sword I use we need to separate
these boys there are three of them this
is not good yeah this is a fire element
which doesn't come out about to die
don't do that okay okay okay I mean if
we can get we need to get a boy hmm
they're all pretty low Oh kind of lowish
just keep it going maybe we could just
get it going yeah I haven't done like a
single spirit blade combo at all and I'm
just I'm hanging out for cheap it's
hanging out with the Chad man yeah I am
I need to I need to get right I need to
get my head in the game what am i doing
oh yeah they're they're not great but
like when I need something that just
kind of does damage and it's a long
sword for me I I kind of fall onto it
it's a good like bass set like I kind of
equate it to the what's that the zorb a
grouse a good like starter you know high
high rank set does a good job of
breaking in exactly
oh this guy's already good now we're
down to one do I should probably like
these boys I mean maybe I would like to
I'd like to actually I like to look at
the set for the boys yeah
please so I can make that happen
I'd actually think that
excuse me I wasn't prepared for that I
wasn't prepared got mom loved streamers
would actually read the chat it's it's a
philosophy and a thing that I've always
tried to make a point whenever I do like
live streams cuz like why would we even
bother doing a thing live if we're not
gonna talk to you
somebody says they'll give us an idea of
how to finish this quest in there in ten
minutes before people I like it
this is good I similar talking about
this quest yeah I mean we've only got do
it one more time - and we've got our
yeah we're pretty cool sunglasses and I
can make all the Wesker quotes I want -
what's your favor Wesker quote seven
minutes seven minutes is all I have to
play with you that's pretty good
complete global saturation yeah that
one's good I like down a lot the way he
says it
yeah emphasis like he's saying it
through like gritted teeth and he's like
just kind of like seething with anger it
seems like pretty good good job being
Wesker well yeah and it was cool because
he specifically tried to emulate forget
the original actor for Wesker at a
live-action one no no no before like in
code Veronica okay it was a different
guy but he specifically tried to emulate
the way back I portrayed Wesker so it
actually has a consistency to it which
is a huge problem I have with Resident
Evil as the series is that there's
almost no consistency in voice actors or
character appearances for any of the
main characters it's very true I think
like Chris had like the most decent run
there for a while with like five and six
but otherwise it was like Leon's
different in every game
Jill is different in every game this
does no consistency and it kind of sucks
yeah it makes it makes it hard to
identify those character what if they
just kept the the real-life actors from
the first game through the whole thing
stuck with that wait you mean those uh
those like Japanese like high school
kids they got to play v we're were they
old with you am I thinking of the same
thing are you thinking of the FMV
opening of Reza navel wand yeah we're
like
Jill Valentine yeah yeah Jojo was like a
it was like a high-school really you're
kiddin high school yeah oh well I got
two tickets I make in my classes now I
got one ticket it's okay we'll run it
we'll run another time and I'm just
gonna be able to do this with the
glasses on lame I'm all suppose I'm
gonna swap my sword feelings for next
Friday what games would they recommend
blood-borne Jacques is zero
especially because right now if you get
ps+ with it blood-borne is 3 and
blood-borne is probably my favorite game
of this console generation it's a very
good video you should definitely pick up
blood-borne I imagine you're probably
gonna get PS Plus assuming you want to
play online yeah yeah forget that and
then get blood-borne Uncharted is a good
call last of us a lot of those cool
exclusive exclusive games that you
missed out on and horizon
[Music]
mr. gamer says titanfall she was super
rad and underrated yes absolutely
that guy's so fantastic shooters
multiplayer is really really good and
the campaigns also surprisingly good as
well trying exclusives oh there's some
good Japanese exclusive especially last
year % of 5 jacques julie JRPGs yaku's
oh yeah Nier automata it's a good time
pretty good as you can't play it on the
PC you can't play it on the PC so it
gives for is your best bet
yeah those are I definitely recommend
those games for sure there we go
shall the Colossus if you hadn't played
that definitely play that this is gonna
be my favorite thing it's just gonna
roll out son clap like sunglasses from
the forge perfect I love it
equip them now oh I don't think you
could just Hammer sunglasses like that
you know you'd be surprised I need to
unhide my helmet
or yeah unhide it because it's my that's
the options to terrorize zeroed on also
fantastic game monster honor if you're
feeling it yeah monster I know it's a
good one my change of this so you get
this going again yeah this is good this
is good this is a good old time I like
that alright let's do it one more so I
can get my glasses and then we'll move
on to the next event
I should probably upgrade them to
upgrade them a little bit to oh yeah
well we'll get the the glasses then
we'll move on to the next cool event
that you can do yeah
upgrade them glasses this is good for
more upgrades remaining we're not gonna
be able to take it all the way but
that's ok man bomber bomber thinking it
to 80 or 68 I should probably put some
I'm gonna come upstairs and I'm gonna
put some slots and things in there it's
got three level one gem slots Oh which
that's pretty good
I'm into I'm down with it Skyrim special
edition is also good if you haven't got
a chance to play Skyrim true doom is oh
very good
yeah the console versions of doom are
actually pretty good mmm-hmm they look
great and they run at 60 I believe I've
been seeing the the work that they've
been putting into the switch version at
all I've heard that they've actually
done some improvements to it which is
good because I didn't really care for
that switch version I like yeah you know
I wanna [ __ ] on them too hard like
obviously you know it's very impressive
it's impressive that it's on switch at
all and I don't deny that but it was
definitely my least favorite version of
that game to play like there's someone
who played it on PC did not feel the
desire until dawn yeah until Dawn's
great console dawn is the best David
cage you could probably get it pretty
cheap too I imagine
yeah like you get that game for like 10
15 bucks like Oh
they're a good time so I have the idea
of one of those already oh why did I get
so many what oh I had them all built up
that's why it's a big big ol mess ah you
know what
sure oh I'm sorry uh our ons
since we're getting ignored I apologize
during their talk about the glasses
they said the sunglass give you a stun
resistant skill - but you need to have
it on level three and use the fire
weapon not a dragon those are not
dragons we're talking about voice which
top my weapon
we're all good I apologize for ignoring
you I got too excited about talking
about PlayStation game same that's it so
I'm just gonna keep using the the
vouchers the whole time Dave already
filled up that was quick
already filled up yeah man already got
everyone everyone in the and the old old
crew god he looks looks like an absolute
tool bag and I love it
an absolute tool bag the reflective
about Far Cry 5 it looks looks ok i'm
not i'm not hyped up on it yet but
there's still time
i can go for some good random am I'm not
opposed to that it's been a while so I
played a far cry
has it has it hasn't been a while since
you played it for crap okay I didn't
play a little bit for recently actually
it's fair enough
I'm thinking like fully oh gosh I've
actually I've actually played a lot of
Far Cry recently I was gonna say like I
I I know about about you're playing a
bunch and I was like what what all right
look I lied I'm playing far cry non-stop
don't what do I gotta call me out don't
drag me god geez where arc arc is pretty
cool
download fortnight it's free it's a lot
of fun p.m. before it's always cool it's
the best way to farm decorations mostly
getting useless ones just get them you
can meld stuff later on but I don't I
know if it was like an efficient way to
just go out and be like I'm gonna get
decorations outside of that let's do it
some of these boys I'm ready let's get
these these cool glasses for you well
I'm just kicking the dirt what a rebel
I'll run over this way close the gate
get a murder on
this is this is a good a good mess
what's happening
come on yup sure all right
oh yeah there's augmentation stuff that
you got to look out for - yeah monster
hunter late game the game it kind of it
slows down cuz you're waiting on a lot
on like drop it does what happen at the
same time you can kind of play a lot of
these events and without without that
stuff and still be fine I think for the
most part yeah you can you can be a fun
casual monster honor if you want yeah it
never requires you to like fully engage
with those stuffs if you don't want to
which is good or onsens don't separate
them their family molina thil will buy
together them will will will save this
guy let them let him get through the
door again is our mistake we messed up
nice too close to it
damn
got that side step is like my favorite
thing I love it so much I missed I miss
real bad and they're not a health
booster
that's nice that was pretty quick I'm
into it
oh wow and then the gate comes down
immediately it's like we planned it
totally calculated every time carved
these boys out oh yeah that's right I
should probably do that before I bring
my friend Jim just gonna ruin everyone's
day really quick okay okay I'm going to
uh I'm gonna stand by the gate oh no we
can't we can't close it yet don't do it
everyone just take this one down with
piercing pods alone that is really good
no oh there's no place to go
mess so much with trying to find rare
fish all day still no no no spawn at all
shoot dude uh actually now that I think
about it I haven't really like even
touched fishing in this game I did it a
little bit and then I totally forgot but
it's pretty good what I remember besides
the fact obviously not getting a good
spawn is not what you need is Mass
Effect Andromeda good I'm gonna let you
feel this one Jean Loup now dang flat
out no it's not
I need any elaboration needed on that or
you just good where it is Mass Effect uh
the original master trilogy is one of my
favorite games of all time and I found
in drama to be a massive disappointment
on pretty much every aspect I thought
the character is there there's some
there's some good care just some good
moments but the writing is pretty weak
comparatively the villains aren't very
interesting or compelling side missions
and activities are really boring the
open worlds are like super dull to like
run around in and I don't find any much
of the dialogue choices and like you
know like options always picking to be
very interesting or like noteworthy the
only thing I can say about that game
that's positive is I thought the combat
was pretty good that's about it
everyone's jumping on this boy it seems
like it's the cool thing to do hold on
let me just get flashed again
I'm just there we go just let me when I
get like one good hit there we go
everything's good everything's not good
I take it back yeah I I couldn't stick
with Mass Effect Andromeda as much as I
enjoyed the original games I beat it
100% Mecca 100% of it I played 60 hours
mastering drama no so I feel like I as
is an authoritative voice can say
definitively that games are good some
aspect and drama to kind of like your
well I'd say Metal Gear survival most
but like that's that's the thing
everyone has to deal with a lot of
people had to deal with Mass Effect when
I came out to be fair yeah yeah I mean
it's maybe the game like I could think
of that I was really excited for and God
maybe burned the most on I'm trying to
think if there's another game that
that's ever done that to me I've been
maybe halo 5 but even then I don't know
because by the time Halo 5 came out like
Halo 5 is probably the weakest halo game
from her campaign standpoint the
multiplayer is actually pretty pretty
good but I was already kind of like
falling off of halo by that point anyway
so it I didn't feel quite as burned it
was just sort of more like oh well I
guess this is sort of the sign that I
can finally stop caring about halo which
is a sad sad thing this which is right
but it was sort of like it was already
going in that direction yeah yeah the
the 3.3 games kind of didn't do much for
me they've got fantastic soundtracks
though they do and I actually like the
story for it yeah yeah the stuff with
Master Chief of Ratana I actually really
like that stuff I think the story at
five is a hot mess I think it's the
weakest campaign in the entire series oh
god I just I just realized cuz I'm like
yeah halo 5 that was the one we're like
yeah yeah yeah and then I realized it
was the one where he plays the two
different teams so every player
different teams there's there's the one
boss in the game that you fight three
times yeah it's the exact same fight
and that fight is like average at best
yeah and they make you fight it three
times
that was that was real rough I like I
like tried to block it out of my memory
it's also a game where it's weird
because if you look at the game at face
value the story's got a lot of problems
still but what's really weird is the
marketing for that game and what that
game actually is just totally different
things like the marketing pitched the
story that the marketing pitched is a
completely different story than what's
in that game in in a lot of ways and
it's really weird because it's like if
you look at face value the stories and
take it for what it is I didn't story
solve problems but I really have a
problem with how about that story was
marketed because it totally pitched a
different narrative that did not it all
happen yeah yeah least Konami save the
middle of your title there's a
disappointment yeah I don't hate it
fault for the way some people do but I'm
not gonna say that I certainly wasn't uh
a little disappointed Mac it let me down
but I still played it let me down but it
it has those moments of brilliance in it
where it just it's weird it's not like a
master sergeant drama to work from like
top to bottom I was totally disappointed
it was just like man like this games got
that good stuff in it yeah yeah but it's
just like it's also got a lot of stuff
in it that I don't like so that was a
war mixed mixed bag for me yeah hey we
should we should talk about good games
yeah he played halo 1 and it was really
really good halo 1 oh yeah really really
good and how about that that pistol that
that awesome halo 1 Magnum throwback oh
my dude looks so gross and I love it you
have to put on regular gear if you want
to wear your I got I got three tickets
down one row I still got one I still got
one you don't even need those other two
I don't don't eat any of them what the
heck what do you what did you do don't
know how did that happen I didn't show
up at all for the highlights though holy
cow three things I did
Oh phone famous 15 I feel bad because I
kind of stopped playing that after like
a couple hours but I actually liked the
open-world parts I found this story
super boring though yeah I thought like
the main plot stuff to be pretty matte
but the rest of it
like I like the whole like just these
boys going on a camping it's my favorite
road trip adventure yeah exactly
I'm like more of that please I took a
whole video game purely based on that as
a premise rather than like oh we got a
dude your dad's dead or something yeah
right
but I was I was really exciting some
like this is gonna be the Final Fantasy
that's for me I'm gonna I'm gonna jump
in and everything's gonna be great it's
gonna be fantastic I couldn't do it but
I'll probably come back I ended up
getting it fairly cheap on the PC with
the Gordon Freeman stuff so I'm gonna
run around as my favorite half-life and
pretend it's it's a different time and
see if I can do it
talk about a good game sure Witcher 3
hell yeah yeah I was um they they
recently did that update on the Xbox one
X where they add a 4k support I haven't
checked it which are - yeah and I don't
necessarily need it because I own which
are 2 on PC and it still looks a little
bit better obviously because you know PC
they kind of like redesigned a lot of it
that games visuals to work on 360
there's a really good digital foundry
video where they kind of talk about that
it's still very impressive but my point
is it just maybe you want to play what
your - man I should just play The
Witcher again get that all those which
were things going again so we're all
we're all prancing up here this is
pretty great I haven't done it but I've
always I keep talking about it I want to
do a like a simultaneous like play
through all three games while also
reading all the books that'd be pretty
good yeah like a Witcher like playing
read yeah yeah like a all senses
everything switched to The Witcher kind
of yeah I'm kind of doing that with
danganronpa right now like I'm watching
the anime I'm playing
games I'm looking for translated
versions of like the weird short stories
and stuff that they have for it
like I've I'm deep diving into that
throw it all it'd I appreciate that and
I'm very very into it what what arm are
you gonna you gonna put on you got some
sweet damascus absorbs or i got i got
machine so that i might just go like a
mix match for a now because I do I want
to finish I also got that Basile yeah
I'm gonna go fish like random set here
look everyone got part of my basil
grease I want to finish those actually
Basile Greaves
Greaves like the name is basil goose
basil geese bears are griefs something
like that it's all the same thing I love
it
to understand the minute Creek or Final
Fantasy 15 at all I actually kind of do
in the sunset I'm like or I guess I
don't know but I can see that game
getting very mixed reactions because I
think yeah everyone kind of feels
differently about that game there's a
party happening over there man we're
turning up dude it's a good time
everyone's stoked
let's get getting pumped on these quests
so we're able to move on to the the next
one now let's do it man let's keep that
ring going what uh what what are we what
are we looking at next so next we are
looking at mock you pop it up and all
I'll just join in host new quests we've
got the triple threat throwdown whoa
which is looks like a good time yeah
it's arena one yeah we should be too bad
is this an older one this is not an
older one this is we haven't done this
but yeah alright
uh I'm going to post it up do it I'm
gonna accept this quest and I mean I'm
actually gonna change my my weapon over
to Maya my explodey switch axe cuz i p1
switch ax e for these guys
there we go now we're now we're in it
man my character looks like a douche
it's it's perfect I love it
oh no I just ordered the meal and
immediately it said another players used
about you dang well I feel so bad oh
wait no it's black star does that way
does that apply to everybody in the
entire set my cuz that's cool if that
does it's be kind of weird if you got a
notification it didn't apply to you
there's so many Sciences so many things
to try and figure out doing the triple
threat quest right now nice I like it
I'm excited for it I like fighting these
guys all specifically because they're
all kind of squishy she's pretty good
karma oh asking about the new headgear
[Music]
they're really cool shades to make you
look really cool so you can you can let
everyone know how cool guy you are while
you're while you're out hunting yeah so
we're actually both wearing them right
now I've got mine tinted to be to be
black oh my god we got some sport shades
over here red eyes has got some some red
red colored ones for red eyes John Lucas
showed up he's also got some some kind
of reddish orangish color going on we're
all just we're all we're all killing it
right now everyone on the rope have we
played quantum break I hadn't
I've played like half of it it's fun
question mark I've heard it's kind of a
little let down yeah which is maybe come
I want to play it because I'm actually a
huge fan of
i strong a blank the studio which proves
I'm not actually it's Max Payne yeah I'm
having a tow Branford remedy yes yes
thank you it's okay clearly I'm a
massive fan of Wren I really love room
look I just love Sam Lake it's that
spine that's an acceptable answer but
Max Payne one and two are fantastic
games and I also really really love Alan
Wake Alan wakes just like that that game
that game does have some flaws but just
by that I stole I still love it come
surprise this Jagger's is not dead yet
and I and I sort of like American
Nightmare
yeah those kind of like a cool like a
they did like a Twilight Zone kind of
yeah I like The Twilight Zone parts the
part where you're basically doing the
same thing three times I do not so much
like so much but I do like the S coat
like the character stuff I like the
little way you're like fmz Alan Wake
evil Alan Wake yeah yeah murdering
people and talking you through a TV I'm
like I'm in it stuff it's cool Jagger
stone oh no think we'll ever get an Alan
link - I'd like to think we would I know
they want it they said eventually but
nothing at the moment no indication yeah
I as much as I wanted I don't know if
that'll happen do you think do you think
the world's ready for a second Alan Wake
I think they can handle it that's the
real question
but you know what I mean I think
Microsoft needs exclusives I think
Microsoft more than anyone could handle
a new yeah at this point they'll take
anything they can get yeah or what if
they just corral everything everything
they've got together and have like a
like a banjo kazooie Alan Wake crossover
a situation like banjo hasn't done
anything for a while I want to see him
somewhere Alan's been kind of
for a sound way can conquer there you go
and up in the void
whatever that area was at the end of
Alan Wake that he gets stuck into
there's a name for it ever it is you
know the nothingness or whatever the
nothing my favorite thing is the nothing
so I think I'm I think I'm trying to
focus the one that does that
the goopy stuff okay I'll try to go for
the the jaggis or Garros yeah right now
I'm adding both though so we're we're
doing pretty okay
I don't think I've been launching you
enough I feel like that's a big missed
opportunity let's skip why it should
probably do that more
I miss playing the switch acts why did I
ever go back to longsword what am I
thinking
oh that boy Slade yeah okay I'm gonna
try and carve him because I actually
would like to get that set so you could
nice sound
I like that set what that's actually not
a bad set to a pair of these glasses
what's gonna say it it'd be perfect for
the glasses okay if you could just not
do your goop thing come over here really
quick - how'd you get the sunglasses so
you got to do the the new event quests
where you fight the the three flashy
Raptors the their name is in the title
of this video I can't even remember it
go red eyes fainted the cheeky boys yes
the t TZ yah Yakub yah
Jack Jack ooh jakku jakku with that
there we go now I'm set for murder
so I hit him right on his right on his
head
oh just kind of rolled over
no I messed up does anyone know how to
get the isère Rathalos quest quest as in
like like what county or an
investigation I mean he'll just kind of
show up in the in the elders a recess
area I think so yeah and then at that
point I think there's a way to maybe get
him it's an option I think I think it's
an optional thing you can fight him as
an optional thing think about how long
ago that was
oh I remember I remember any of my time
playing this game not to high rank at
all thought that boy I think you know I
have fun that boy yes I thought the blue
yeah that's awesome
there's a good good rock drop nice it's
gonna sit here and record the intro for
my okay the dragon a Turkey's hold on
fix nailed it I just decapitated
everybody over there can't believe this
uh uh put my hands up
Modern Warfare 3 was good I like kind of
the older Call of Duty games pretty well
I didn't particularly care for my
warfare 3 but my favorite I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna I don't want to show
anyone who likes I don't want to show of
anyone period exactly if you like any of
the games that we've said we didn't like
that is absolutely fine
games are subjective you do what you
want to do unless it's Mass Effect
Andromeda unless it's effective time I
kid sort of dang hey I made it the
ailment master and the slinger sniper
action bastard fantastic name wants to
know what the glasses stats are we can
check it out I've actually upgraded mine
a bit but cool actually you can check
yours I don't think you've you've done
anything yours haven't oh can we can get
a flat flat stats for you so you can you
can see exactly where it's it's that
when you make them yeah I I like black
ops one a lot I still think that might
be my favorite Call of Duty mm-hmm see
they did the I think that's the best the
best the zombies had ever been dead ops
arcade was in there you could play Zork
oh yeah it had really cool story yeah it
was a good time oh my harvest boxes full
everything is full ones pretty good I
think I think that's that's where I lie
on the what called you yes I am I also
know a lot of people love black ops 1
multiplayer maybe the most I know
apparently like the hardcore like
eSports like Call of Duty people think
black ops 2 is the best yeah yeah
there's a lot of stuff with with to I
couldn't get into to unfortunately as
much as I'd like to but it was fun but
pretty alright time over to myself yeah
yeah see it's yeah they got a base
defense
of 46 which is okay but they do got
three gem slots plus five for to fire
none thing to water for - Thunder - to
ice and then to Dragon that's pretty
good it's got stunning resistance if we
upgrade it here open it up I know are
you the only one talking in twitch chat
maybe possibly we see you I can get all
the way up to I got two upgrades
remaining and it is a 64 so I believe I
get it - 68 max which is pretty good
yeah so yeah not the best set but pretty
decent for it they are the eye patches
is better I do like the eye patch a lot
aesthetically but I mean the sunglasses
though yeah that wiggly hat though gosh
we're the wiggly hat more all right so
we've done that Kanto cancels my the
only one talking the twitch Chad yeah
actually not many people on the twitch
chat today although yeah we are doing it
too so maybe just everything normally
watching twitch so this is old and this
is old so that means we've got to do our
simple task quests let's do it get these
ten gourmet shroom caps I'm gonna wait
till you're loaded in before I pick it
thank you so don't want let's do that
and then we can do some other really
cool punt things we'll do like an ear
you got a to end it how about sounds
like a plan
I like it are you two on different
consoles yeah where we got to two games
set up and where we're playing with each
other and it's a good time yeah Oishi
switch back to yours all right I'm just
gonna drop in at the beginning cam
alright I have no idea for this I
wouldn't you know I might I might just
do it for fun
oh really well here's the thing also cuz
I only play on Fridays anyway I end up
getting all these well there is this oh
no I have a really cool investigation we
could do hold on or someone else had I
did it get full up and you'd back out
you guys are excited and I'm excited
that you're excited
dang I'm sorry I got ya caught up in
that voucher game it's understandable
all rights for people all good southwest
camp oh that's sweet a party of none
says I heard you over on YouTube and
came to join you in the twitch chat
that's well there you go eat
no got we I got got pals uh I can't tow
cam says oh yeah thank you I'm gonna
distract it again oh did it I didn't use
my factory though that's to nervous
that's okay it's understandable says but
you guys are willing to pay money for a
new zone with a bunch of new monsters I
hope that a snow zone yeah I pay for
that yeah I feel like the scheme is
missing a snow zone yeah if they were if
they were just straight-up like hey
here's like a ten fifteen dollar
expansion and then adds like a whole new
zone plus like say like seven monsters
or so I pay that yeah it's like ten to
15 bucks be a good old time oh yeah cool
I get a free meal yeah we actually got
it this time there's a carryover from
that meal earlier if someone else did it
this time that works
the weapons look dope in this game yeah
I'm way into this this switch axe is one
of my favorites by far and it matches
the whole like kind of red aesthetic I
got going on - it's a good time
a lot of good whistles happening there
hmm are you wearing to you with it
shades basically how much the one of the
new event quests that we put up this
week lets you get sunglasses so you can
walk around looking your coolest party
events as I believe all DLC monsters
have been free in the past that is true
and that is the plan for this one as
well they haven't announced that they're
doing any paid DLC but I've got that I
just yeah if they were if I had to pay
to get like a whole new zone cuz I
imagine that would take a lot of work
I'm looking for that yeah oh we're
getting a I got tempered Anja NASA found
some temper danger Ness so from what I
hear this we thought it was gonna be the
angry pickle boy but it's actually just
a way to kind of get tempered monster
tracks
oh is that what it's for basically
because I'm finding a ton of temper
tangent app yeah what does actually
should we fight a temper to Angeles I
don't know if it I don't know if it's
here but it'd be a good time
cuz wait because it's deep from the
tracks and then it unlocks an
investigation isn't that how it works
yeah but as gonna say we got that we got
that stream that they're doing next week
for Monster Hunter we're I'm sure
they're gonna talk about new o new
things like stars dawn damn shrooms I
have no idea where we find these I don't
need their entries we're looking for so
we're probably just gonna be walking
around not knowing where we're going
actually I do know where you find them
oh really
yeah I know where to find a couple I'm
gonna I'm gonna head over to where you
guys are cuz I'm I think one of our boys
already on it I'm a mess yeah Black
Stars already at this farming spot oh
wait I do know where you get these
nevermind they're they're inside the
like colonies that you gotta like take a
unique mushroom colonies that's the one
because there is like an elite quest for
this that I remember doing okay yeah
I'll call these birds he's cool Birds
I would run into like any proper
monsters yet which is kind of a thing I
guess oh that guy found zero rep lows
good job
tempered look at that new goose a
tempered grass looks sure
Bhagu goose yeah it's hard pass harvest
she's gotta go was good hanging out with
you arm it and I hope you have a good
rest of your day and a good weekend
thank you for stopping by
look forward to seeing you in the chat
again they always always appreciate it
why is it so hard to do multiplayer with
your friends in this game it it's kind
of awkward but once you guys kind of get
I hate that you gotta kind of give it
like a like a caveat but like once you'd
get past like the the story stuff it
kind of gets easier because you just
show up and go yeah all that stuff like
the cutscenes kind of sucks yeah why is
the music oh it's because these things
so these these boys right here use
threat level 2 tracks that can add to
investigation anymore so it literally is
just to kind of farm out tempered
investigations on okay that's kind of
cool yeah I'm gonna do it I haven't I
haven't seen you why it's the hunter
rank 30 yeah what do we got here oh yes
this is exactly what we need more more
bagel goose misfired scales it's right
level two Purple's yeah it's too much
purple for me you might have to pass on
that one
oh that's not for Pooky Pooky that's
more myself to see more streams from us
keep up the good work thank you we are
we start every Friday's needle they kick
us out until they tell us Mawson hunters
relevant then we're gonna plead to play
a different game yeah no we'll figure
something else out I don't know if we
don't have a concrete plan yet but I'm
really hoping to make see if deep so a
weekly thing for at least a couple weeks
I'm Nick is Nick is
absolutely down to do that I think Jake
is as well though I little bit I played
with them today was my first time
playing and I actually really liked it
so now it's also be down to participate
in that stream that sounds pretty fun
what I don't think I could keep up with
Nick I think he's just gonna play that
game oh he's forever he's gonna deep
dive into that one yeah it's gonna be a
heck of a time all right guys time to
place these and he's already like a
legendary pirate he's he's solo piloting
like a four person ship and he's got all
the best gear I can see it uh Erin
Keaney wants to know how many hours are
in your file
oh I'm just under 200 games I'm not
thank you like I think I'm just under
100 like one like 150 is around where I
kinda like I feel like I've seen
everything I need to see a temper uh
Toby katashi nation but uh yeah listen I
think this might be my most played
Monster Hunter at this point return to
base yeah so to keep grabbing all these
different stations get as much a scan
yeah that's you thank you
trying to school coins for lines forever
uh yeah I know exactly who saw mo cuz
I'm trying to do the same thing I really
like it God my guy looks awful every
time all right then let's do New Yorker
Conte I'm into it ding - hunter ranks
just hanging out so this dream what
hunter rank of mine I think I'm like we
just saw it pop up and I think I'm like
only like a low 50s
like not not too high I mean high in a
sense but not like way high I've
definitely slowed down my monster huntin
no five hours in unlocking it a lot just
have so many games
you've ever had in previous master
hunters so not necessarily transmog but
like so right now here I can show it
just because I've loaded in right they
have the one set that you can do it with
so uh I'm 50/50 on the transmog on the
one hand I like it in the sense that I
want maybe my stats and my gear to be
separate from each other but on the
other end I do feel like the look of the
armors so tied to the monsters you're
hunting so I don't know I'm kind of
50/50 on it yes like you can you can
transmog your gear to look like this if
you have the special edition so the
ability to do it is there yes they have
it built in apparently generations did
transmog generations is the one I had a
I had a rough time with so I think
that's when they added no it was cross
that they added the the styles I I
couldn't I couldn't get down with the
styles
GameStop thinks is the best Monster
Hunter game I'll let you know when I get
to them yeah asking for you yeah it's
it's a very very good monster on our
game definitely crosses generations ok
see there you go yeah I I had a hard
time dealing with the the different
styles in it and I just kind of fell off
but I really wish the double cross came
out over here though even with it still
having styles God all your armor set
just looks so much cooler than mine mmm
just looking for a new look yeah I feel
like I have enough to do the these boys
oh there you go so I just need to figure
out those goggles though the color
payments generations in the is
generations is the US version European
is gotcha
it was it was different names in
different place
this this makes sense that make sense
but yeah I I like I like the ones
without like like it's cool Italy put
that stuff in to kind of mix it up but
I'm glad that they went back to not
having styles in world okay definitely
definitely the be said I prefer you see
I want that I want the double cross
localized I almost imported it but I was
kind of afraid by imported I mean I just
bought a digital code but no be really
cool do we ever do we won't do temper'd
near Gurgaon site do we have that that's
not a thing
yeah something baby I'm pretty sure
that's the thing let me check and see if
I have something for it I haven't been
keeping up on my investigations at all
like stars has helped me with tempered
Kyrian uh you know I'm sure we don't
have not a will do will do tempered
Karen I don't so I guess that might be
where we're headed let's do it
I'm okay with that that's not a bad way
to change up my gear really quick was a
tempered Val has akka that's a real I
mean I really do want that guys set but
will help with the Karen we said we
don't we'll do a Karen thing so uh let
us know when yeah yeah give me a sec I
need to I'm doing
no worries wishbone truth be told even
in our office we sometimes slip up yeah
yeah sorry we were trying to make fun of
you that's just a light little goof
because we say that all the time as well
it's the only way we can deal with the
pain is to laugh about it but yeah yeah
no worries have we beaten double-cross
on the 3ds have not do you have to spend
any money on content for this so there
are extra like yeah there is like
there's a emotes for like Street Fighter
that was kind of like a little much in
the price right yeah they're like it's
like four dollars to be able to do a
Hadouken I didn't like that
I got an admit I was not a fan oh wait
it's the assigned one
thunderous Rumble yeah it's you can buy
emotions off but like the actual content
like monsters and the new quests in the
new gear that all its just given to you
you're just kind of I can get into that
all right I'm gonna change
oh hey you know Jeeva finally it's an
assigned one no someone else joined also
apparently my hunter ring cuz my enough
dang dang dude oh yeah I have to be 49
for that if you have a tempered NER you
can't say cuz we can do that
I'll check might might drop out of this
really quick find out you stay in there
just in case because if I don't I say
you do that and I'll just watch okay
some some temper no I got regular New
Yorker got a temper tangent a tempered
it change also well wait I need to
actually go check my investing I kind of
forgot you got to go talk to the lady
[Music]
hold on a sec everyone did you all good
I'm messing with my gear right now oh
yeah you have to be plus 54 tempered
elders so I probably even have tempered
near grant a then so yo now let's do you
oh you do it I'll watch all right I'm
I'm down I'm gonna mess with this stuff
and yeah and I'm definitely swap this
out for my Thunder proof mansell
cleanser don't really need it so I'm
gonna use health this fight isn't a joke
like at all where my glasses at I need
to keep these on the most important
thing
I'm just gonna use all my Xena jiva
stuff oh no what happen I got kicked out
of the quests on now but yeah what end I
don't think so I don't know I'm gonna
eat my food then I'll get up and check
see it said there was a connection error
and oh no I'm back in
Oh maybe something just happened with it
host a new quest you wanna join I don't
want to post new quests I just get
excited I'm so used to just jumping in
there we go yes
don't use about you for that that hot
Kieran set that Ravens very a very
intense fight but I don't release to my
site which is fair I should use my
switch axe no yes no yes
so I quest cancel automatically no
worries my dude
Oh weird we're all we're all here to
hang out and do a thing it'll be a good
time no rush we got one more spot in
here if anyone wants to join up awesome
I think I'm yeah I'm still still full
food I'm I'm set
I'm ready to hunt - Kieran
three the temperature and quest to fight
temper tell the Dragons yeah this is
like the Gateway quest into it
interesting which is at some point I'm
yeah yeah
tempered monsters don't mess around
though yeah they really down or armor
looks so intense what are the skills um
I think the main thing for this set is
it makes it so that like elemental
things don't happen to you so basically
you can't catch on fire that kind of
stuff it's been a while since I've used
it so I've been more into my auto Garen
business but it looks intense though for
sure yeah great swords better the Z no
crew that's us
you got to get that resistance where you
can cuz I'm just afraid to not have it
afraid to not have the resistance at all
why don't I go here I know it's not here
bulls II know everything except for my
my cool sunglasses but yeah great sword
it's not my bag I can't I can't hang out
with it I can't do it I used to be able
to but no I'm just a sad long sword boy
do you it cool so I'm kind of nervous
about this mm-hmm but I'm excited
haven't fought a temperature and since I
had to for this quest so did you did you
beat it
oh yeah it took it took a couple of
tries but found him wait till everyone
else shows up I don't want to jump in
one of them here or that dude jump for
it I mean Oh make it happen see here not
too far away
you mean he's talking about our cosmetic
stuff you'd like to see talked about
this before but uh yeah they mention it
doesn't make cry which I think we've
mentioned freaking one that we didn't
think of was Dino Crisis ah yes please
where is the Dino Crisis bring back all
the dormant have not made a databases
really long time yeah it sucks they
stopped after two right yeah you know
what I like to see another one Clevenger
glad they didn't do anything crazy like
put dinosaurs in space
that'd be wacky
yeah
bring me some cool power stone stuff I'd
like to have luck out like an Edward
Falcon outfit pottsy's confirming what
we already were suspecting which is
there's a reddit post I'm a full bureau
skier and sunglasses that make you look
like neo from the matrix perfect
which just glad to know that's that's
someone else thought of that it's out
there exists someone's already put it
out into the universe this is exactly
what we needed
ooh ventures bosom says a jurassic world
event set
that'd be pretty good oh come on don't
do this to me I just like I saw it out
of the corner of my eye and I'm like
really stopping it no ow look guys this
is it's fine you get one out of the way
so that the curent thinks that it has a
fighting chance yeah exactly we don't
secure yeah we don't we don't die
anymore after this point we're all good
we're all professionals everything's
fine here leave me this is the Jason X
of Dino Crisis - yikes that's very apt
you know what I would uh I would play
that Friday the 13th game again if they
added a Jason EXO stage are they like a
proper like I'm not just not just the
character you like a proper stage they
are okay well I'm gonna have to eat my
own words and literally play that game
again so that's awesome
there's a giant easter egg were you go
through this virtual cabin thing that
they put into the game and at the end of
it it basically takes you through and
you like come out on a space station and
wow that was very quick are you coming
on a space station and then Jason X
walks out of like an airlock so that's
that's there all right I'm on board for
forefront of the team all right oh sorry
Black Star that went so quick
that's rough we might not have time for
I realize what time yeah wow yeah we do
not have time unfortunately for anything
I'll shoot today especially I would just
like to sit here played mobster honor in
this hot hot sweaty room it is very
spicy very cool boy yeah thank you
everybody for tuning in for this week's
Monster Hunter Fridays it's a good great
time as always but you can always stay
in the session you know there's plenty
of people there so hopefully you guys
can hang out in place of Monster Hunter
he'll black star beat tempered Kirin
yeah that'd be pretty cool do that and
yeah like he like been said earlier in
the stream we stream every weekday at
11:00 always got something new on the
horizon and yeah we're gonna have a lot
of cool there's some good stuff coming
out yeah it seems it's gonna be a good
time for crime sure gonna cover all
those games so stay tuned for that and
see you guys next time
you